ce jeudi l'espagne a rendu hommage aux
plus de 28000 mort du co vie de 10,9 sur
son territoire la cérémonie a eu lieu à
madrid en présence de dirigeants de
l'union européenne et d'organisations
internationales
le roi philippe et 6 s'est adressé au
peuple espagnol
aujourd'hui est un jour que nous
capterons de notre mémoire
un jour qui restera gravé dans nos
coeurs car aujourd'hui nous rendons
hommage avec tout notre respect qu est
la plus haute solennité de la tâche aux
milliers de citoyens qui ont perdu la
vie à cause de la pandémie de kobe 19
aujourd'hui est aussi un jour qui
restera gravé dans nos consciences
parce que nous reconnaissons et loue les
milliers de citoyens dont les
comportements était le meilleur exemple
jeu des valeurs civiques et morales de
notre société est la meilleure raison de
notre espoir collectif
le confinement en espagne a fortement
impacté l'économie du pays
à barcelone ce restaurateur alerte sur
l'importance de la reprise dans son
secteur et n'envisage pas un deuxième
confinement il a peur que nous avons
c'est de devoir à nouveau fermé nous
avons déjà été fermés longtemps alors
maintenant ce dont nous avons besoin
c'est que les gens prennent conscience
du problème qu'il réfléchisse bien parce
que c'est un problème mondial à cet
important qu'ils réfléchissent bien
parce que c'est un problème mondial
assez important et ça va être dur car si
les gens ne devraient même pas
conscience du problème
il va continuer à y avoir des rebonds et
on aura encore des problèmes
les espagnols ont vécu l'un des co
finement les plus strictes d'europe et
le port du masque est rendue plus
compliquée à cause des fortes chaleurs
avant tout je pense que ce geste est
important pour tous il nous protège nous
mais aussi ceux avec lesquels nous nous
trouvons c'est très important
après avec la chaleur et tout ça peut
déranger et quelquefois ça peut même
accablé
mais c'est véritablement très important
pour nous et pour les autres
l'espagne est l'un des pays européens
les plus affectés par la pandémie selon
l'université john hopkins le pays des
contes 250000 infections coronavirus
pour 28 1413 décès